>> Laura: TIME FOR "SEEN
AND UNSEEN."
WHERE WHERE HE UNPACK THE
BIG CULTURAL STORIES OF THE
DAY.
RAYMOND ARROYO JOINS ME NOW.
JOHNNY DEPP WAS GRANTED A
BIG WIN IN HIS DEFAMATION
LAWSUIT AGAINST HIS EX,
AMBER HEARD TODAY.
>> LAURA, THE COURT AWARDED
DEPP $15 MILLION IN TOTAL
WHICH COULD LIKELY BUY ABOUT
FOUR BLACK PEARLS.
AS I ARGUED FROM THE
BEGINNING, AND YOU'LL
REMEMBER THIS, JOHNNY DEPP
ONE THIS TRIAL THE MOMENT
THE JUDGE ALLOWED THE
CAMERAS IN, BECAUSE IT GAVE
HIM THE OPPORTUNITY TO TELL
HIS SIDE OF THE STORY AND
RECLAIM HIS REPUTATION, AND
THEREBY WORK AGAINST.
IN TRUTH, THE PUBLIC WAS THE
REAL JURY AND SAY WHAT YOU
WANT ABOUT THE ARGUMENTS,
JOHNNY DEPP WAS A
FASCINATING PRESENCE ON THE
STAND AND AMBER HEARD NOT SO
MUCH.
>> I WAS JUST SITTING THERE
ON THIS CARPET LOOKING AT
THE DIRTY CARPET WONDERING
HOW I WOUND UP ON THIS
CARPET AND WHY I WAS NEVER
-- WHY I NEVER NOTICED THAT
THE CARPET WAS SO FILTHY
BEFORE.
>> HE CAME TO NEW YORK HE
CAME TO FIGHT FOR OUR
RELATIONSHIP.
>> DON'T CALL ME A LIAR.
DON'T CALL ME A LIAR.
>> IN THEATER, LAURA, THEY
CALL THAT "SQUEEZING THE
PITY OUT OF THE
PERFORMANCE."
WHETHER SHE WAS TELLING THE
TRUTH OR NOT, THE
CREDIBILITY WAS WHAT WAS AT
STAKE HERE AND THE JURY AND
THE PUBLIC DIDN'T FEEL SHE
HAD IT, THAT SHE WAS FAKING,
BUT THE BIG NEWS HERE IS THE
CULTURAL COMPONENT WHICH IS
JOHNNY DEPP TAKING DOMESTIC
ABUSE OF MEN OUT OF THE
SHADOWS AND INTO THE CENTER
OF THE CULTURE FOR THE FIRST
TIME.
I THINK WE'LL BE SEEING A
LOT MORE OF JOHNNY DEPP IN
THEATERS SOON.
>> AND SPEAKING OF TROUBLED
COUPLES, WHAT IS GOING ON
WITH THE FIRST LADY JILL
BIDEN?
>> WELL, FIRST LADY JILL
BIDEN IN A NEW HARPER'S
BAZAAR INTERVIEW REVEALS
THAT SHE AND THE PRESIDENT
HAVE THEIR FIGHT VIA TEXT.
SHE CALLED IT SEXTING, ONLY
LIKE HER HUSBAND,
COMMUNICATION CAN BE A
PROBLEM, LAURA.
SEXTING IN THE URBAN
DICTIONARY MEANS TEXTING
WHILE HAVING INTERCOURSE.
>> Laura: WHY IS SHE
FIGHTING OVER TEXT, THOUGH?
>> SHE CLAIMS SHE DOESN'T
WANT THE SECRET SERVICE TO
HEAR THEM FIGHTING.
AS BIDEN REMINDED HER,
EVERYTHING THAT THEY TEXT
ENDS UP IN THE NATIONAL
ARCHIVES.
THE PEOPLE IN THE HALL CAN'T
HEAR YOU BUT ALL OF
POSTERITY WILL SOON BE ABLE
TO READ ALL THE NASTY THINGS
YOU SAID TO YOUR HUSBAND
WHEN A MAN IS COGNITIVELY
CHALLENGED, HE'S GOT
PRESSURES AND STRESSES,
LAURA, WHY ARE YOU TEXTING
HIM NASTY THINGS AND CALLING
HIM NAMES?
THAT'S PROBABLY NOT THE BEST
TACT AT THE MOMENT.
>> Laura: MAYBE SHE'S
UPSET BECAUSE HE DOESN'T
CALL HER DOCTOR JILL.
>> WE'LL CHECK THE ARCHIVES
FOR THAT EVIDENCE.
>> Laura: THE PRESIDENT
HAD MORE TROUBLE TODAY,
DIDN'T HE, AS HE UNVEILED
THE BABY FORMULA PLAN.
THIS IS TODAY'S BIDEN BY THE
NUMBERS.
>> TODAY WE'RE ANNOUNCING
UNITED AIRLINES AGREED TO
OFFER CARGO SPACE FOR.
[INDISCERNIBLE]
CARE FOR 3.7 BOTTLES OF THE
FORMULA.
>> THAT'S 3.7 MORE BOTTLES
THAN THEY HAD BEFORE.
THIS IS PROGRESS WE DON'T
WANT TO LIMIT IT.
I THINK HE MEANT
3.7 MILLION.
>> Laura: WELL, THE
NUMBERS CAN BE VERY
CONFUSING AFTER